from the very beginning the Russo
brothers have stated that infinity war
it was really a story about Thanos with
all six stones I could simply snap my
fingers they would all cease to exist
and I call that Lucy Thanos has been
described as the biggest baddest and
most ruthless villain in the MCU and we
saw that in Avengers infinity war but if
he's so bad and so ruthless why didn't
he kill any of the Avengers after allthe
anos is known for killing people every
planet he goes to he kills half of the
population on each planet but if you
noticed theist doesn't really ever go
out of his way to kill anybody unless he
has to but he certainly had many
opportunities to kill some of the
Avengers especially when they were
attacking him so why didn't he well
thanks again to the Avengers Infinity
Ward the art of the movie art book we
have an answer
reminder that I'm still giving away
copies of Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and
ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray as well
as some special edition posters for you
a chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe like the video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero in the artbook we
have commentary from Ryan Manor Dean
Ryan is the head of visual development
at Marvel Studios and in the commentary
he spoke a little bit about Thanos
stating the plan of getting all the
Infinity stones is putting him in a
position of being so powerful that he is
sort of calmer more single-minded and
more reasonable he is not necessarily
worried about killing the heroes as long
as he ends up with the stones he can
accomplish what he wants that was sort
of the place where we were starting we
were trying to find looks that were more
casual because he wouldn't really need
his armor after he had gathered more
than one Infinity stone so this is a
direct answer of waif a knows didn't
kill the heroes killing the heroes was
not the main goal or any part of the
plan on Thanos collecting the Infinity
stones his main goal was to collect the
stones
Thanos doesn't go around murdering
people that's not his main focus he has
a goal Thanos doesn't see himself as the
villain he sees himself as a hero in a
very very ironic way Thanos isn't trying
to wipe out half of the universe to kill
people he's trying to do it to save
people
when I'm done half of humanity will
still be alive this is what the rooster
brothers had to say about vanos not
killing any of the heroes Thanos is
violent and cruel it's interesting
because Astana's moves forward from this
moment once he disposes of his armor he
almost becomes a holy warrior he doesn't
spend a lot of his energy intentionally
trying to murder people unless they are
in some way a threat to his agenda this
connects back to Ryan Maynard Dean's
quote when he said vanna's wouldn't
really need his armor after he had
gathered more than one Infinity stone
which is why we see him take off his
armor after he gathers two Infinity
stones because at that time nobody was
really a threat to Fanus anymore
he just defeated Thor and what was left
of Asgard using the Power Stone only and
he defeated the Hulk without using any
Infinity stones at all so famous his
main purpose and goal is to collect all
the Infinity stones to perform the snap
and like the Russo brothers said Thanos
isn't really worried about killing
anybody unless they're going to be a
threat to his plan and once he collects
more than one Infinity stone there
really is nobody left that's a threat to
him which is why he takes off his armor
so that's why fan OHS didn't kill any of
the Avengers and Avengers infinity war
but an Avengers for The Avengers are
going to seek to undo theosis snap so
they could potentially become a threat
to Thanos again if this is so do you
think any of the Avengers will
permanently die in avengers' for let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything related to Avengers infinity
war and Avengers 4 as always thank you
all so much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]